[موسيقى]
انت عارف ايش يسمون دولتك في اوروبا الرجل
المريض
كل الحين قاعد انتظره يموت
الكل مجتمع يبغى يسقط دوله الاسلام بعد
نوضع
[موسيقى]
مرحبا
مؤلمه بعد 100 عام هذا هو مسلسل سفر اللي
كان مفاجاه الموسم الدرامي الرمضاني
الضخمه عن كارثه التهجير الجماعي اللي
طبقتها الدوله العثمانيه عام
1915 تجاه الالاف من الرجال والنساء
والاطفال من سكان المدينه المنوره حدث
تاريخي كان من المهم جدا للدراما ان
تتناولوا يوما هذا حدث
له قيمته التاريخيه وايضا قيمته الانسانيه
ويعتبر اليوم وكانه جريمه حرب لانه تم
تهزيرها هذه المدينه حتى قيل في كثير من
مصادر التاريخيه انه لم يبقى الا 41 شخص
من اهالي المدينه
يقتلون المدينه المنوره تم تهجيرا بالكامل
العمل يروي حكايه السعودي عبد الرحمن
المدايني ورفاق دراسه الجامعيه في اسطنبول
السوري يحيى واللبنانيين فايز وفريد حيث
يخوض الاصدقاء الاربعه رحله الوعي السياسي
والانتقال من اروقه التحصيل العلمي الى
جبهات القتال مع الجيش العثماني اولا في
معارك البلقان على الحدود الروسيه ومن ثم
التمرد على ظلم السلطنه العثمانيه ووحشيه
ممارساتها انا فعلا
حاسس في اسطنبول الابنيه التفاصيل
الديكورات المحلات اللبس المترو العربيات
الحنطور التفاصيل التفاصيل التفاصيل جدا
كلها موجوده وكلها موضوعه بعنايه لدرجه
انه فعليا الواحد فينا بيصدقني اسطنبول
بالارز لما صورنا على حدود البلقان كان
كمان شي كتير حلو لانه عبد الرحمن مثلا
كثير كان بالنسبه له الثلج كثير كبير
وكثير كان الجو حلو هناك وما حسينا حالنا
يعني انه افترقنا هلا كتير اشتقنا للسات
هون كمان بس مره كان كمان كانت مغامره
لقلنا انا وعبد الرحمن ويحيى الجمهور
والنقاد تفاعلوا مع العمل باهتمام كبير
هنا بعد التغريدات
[موسيقى]
اذا كان مكتوب على اهل يحاربوني
اولى في جهادهم ودمهم